[Music]
to start with
i'll just ask what is this populist
moment that we are currently
experiencing
well what i understand is the fact that
we are experiences
experiencing a sense of resistance
to the what i call the post-democratic
condition which has been the consequence
of 30 years of neoliberal
germany in which by bypass democracy i
mean in fact two aspects there is one
which i call post politics
is the fact that uh the this i developed
in my book on the political
uh is the fact that uh no because of the
basically i will say the uh responsible
of that at the uh
social democratic party the center left
with
move you know so much towards the center
that finally
there is no basic difference between the
policy that they offer house and the
right center left
so it means that when the citizen go to
vote well i mean they don't really have
a choice you know it is
and so that's what i call post politics
the lack
of a possibility of alternative for a
citizen election
and of course by that i understand
basically what's at stake is the idea
of popular sovereignty that's one aspect
of the
democratic condition the other one uh is
a
process of only accusation of our
societies
and that's the consequence of the
primacy
of financial capital you know during the
leader
of neoliberal germany and the fact that
as a consequence of that
i mean we've seen a freely a process of
popularization and fragilization not
only of course of the popular classes
but also
of the middle class which are some
people are in speaking of the
disappearance of the middle class so
those two aspects you know post politics
and oligarchization of our societies
and by that of course i understand the
fact that a consequence of the politics
of austerity
and as i was saying financial capitalism
there has been an exponential increase
in equality
you know we've got a real gulf between a
group um
each time smaller that is very
becoming very very richer and the rest
of the people was you know
really in a process of recognization and
popularization
uh well since i will say
the the the beginning of the 2000
i will put 2011 we're beginning to see a
lot of resistance again again against
that
normal movement of the uh occupy wall
street the indignados in spain
and um at the beginning
very beginning that was basically the
the the
it manifested itself to right-wing
populism it was more of the writing
police parties who were
uh presenting themselves uh giving the
answer to that you know and say oh well
we are going to give back the people the
the um voice that they've been
confiscated by the elites
but what is interesting is that more
recently with the development of
the first uh um series scientists that
unfortunately
came to power but was not able to
implement it's for example because of
the the uh what we can really call the
financial coup of the european union
but then podemos in spain only men also
in in
in france so those are movement uh anti
uh a sister movement but from the point
of view of the left this is what i call
the populist moment
you know the the fact that both from the
level of
side of the left and the right they are
resistances against
you know basically we are living a
crisis of neoliberalism
which and we are you know different
people who are
putting into question the system but
fortunately you know we are not
yet in a moment in which a clear
alternative ah it's a woman
she called that you know an interregnum
an organic crisis and i think that's
very characteristic
of what i call the populist moment you
say in this post
politics world that there is no
alternative
is there are there degrees of
alternative is someone
like bernie sanders alexander
ocasio-cortez jeremy corbyn a democratic
specialist absolutely absolutely in fact
this is
when i gave example of what i call a
left populism
i also give an example bernie sanders
jeremy corbyn because you know
left papillion is a strategy
not something it doesn't you don't need
to have a party
for instance the the labour party within
culture i know we've become a left
populist party of course not
but one can say that the the labour
party under jeremy corbyn
is implementing a left popular strategy
and so with bernie sanders
in the same way you know as melanchon
and iglesias
but of course it takes different form
according to the different countries you
know
so not that there is one lipophilic
strategy
but basically the left popular strategy
means
what is crucially both in all cases
is for thinking to question the negemon
egymony of neoliberalism and that is
very clear in the case of corbin you
know there's a break with the
post-politics of blair and it came in
also in many other countries so this
this is what i understand by the
population
so you say possibly quite rightly that
um the way that left populism is
developing is
um context dependent so it's different
in different countries
but to resist neoliberalism which is a
global phenomenon which may articulate
itself differently
in different countries but still
operates in a global way
how do we intercept the different ways
in which left populism
develops and articulates itself between
countries
um to create an internationalist leftist
populist front
well i think that
one should begin you know at home so to
speak even if
if om is is is understood european union
over the context of europe you know
because um i i think that
all the different conjuncture needs to
be understood differently for instance
in my book foreign
i say clearly that i'm examining the
conjunctive today
in western europe and that i don't
include
in that the situation in for instance
post-communist countries because i don't
think that the same kind of analysis
can be used to understand the urban in
hungary or kazinski in in poland because
those countries have got a very
different history from our history you
know and and the the
the fact that they've been under
community domination is something which
is
really important so i i i think that one
i don't believe one can make analysis
and i know that people will you know
they agree with me but
i think that one always need to start
from a specific
conjunction uh in fact i'm even saying
that in the case of europe
one need to begin instead of being say
okay let's
let's uh establish a european project of
populism i say no let's begin by
thinking what should we do in return
and then of course establish a synergy
between the different movement because
obviously there's no way we can
in europe fight against neoliberalism
only at the level of france or
also so that's very important but you
need to start
from a national
things and of course obviously there are
a series of issues on which for instance
it will be very important to establish
some kind of
international collaboration of julie for
instance the question of environment
but all that my uh point is that we
always need to begin you know from
the concrete situation and then
establishing a reason
and i don't think it made sense to think
what kind of you know
international uh strategy could be
developed to fight against
neoliberality for instance you know and
i
i know very well because i'm very close
to a latin america i go there very often
in the situation it is very different
you know of course we've got
things in common of course they are
fighting against neoliberalism
but they are fighting according to a
condition which are very different so
once we have established a
different movement then of course it's
important to
have uh you know moment of um
in in which we are going to help to
establish collaboration
but it should not be something coming
from you know
the the top and and then going back to
uh bottle
i think for instance one of the problem
with the alter globalization movement
uh and the fact that you know it is more
more or less disappear no is because
they
were not really establishing rules in
their different countries you know
you had all those uh activists
meeting in in portal and
among them a lot were ong you know so
that also was a little bit of a problem
because these are not really
of usually very grasshooded in countries
you know
so um and they were meeting and having
fantastic
discussion among you know people from
india from but then those people were
going back
in their country and they did not have
any real
impact there you know so i i think that
that we need to
and i've been discussing that with
several of my friends who were very
involved
in the laboratory movement and they are
saying yeah that was the problem
you know so now we they acknowledge the
fact that no we need to start from the
national
and then go to the occasional and after
that of course you know they may be an
international form of solidarity
but not the other way around as you've
just described
um establishing how we establish
left populism is con is context
dependent
is dependent on which which country
we're living in
but before we move into the specifics
possibly of the uk
are there lessons that can be drawn
between the models
of left populism that are being
developed
across different countries
well i mean it depends what you
understand by the different countries
different countries of the european
union
or between
the experiences because when where they
have been really interesting experiences
of
left population not in america for
instance no and i think of course we've
got to to
to to learn from um
what have been a difficulties because
it's true that
after what they've called the pink uh
wave
now we have been seeing in the last
years
i'm kind of coming back to right-wing
government but i don't think by the way
that this is going to uh follow
the same pattern because for instance we
are going to have next month
very important election in argentina
where it's
almost certain that they will be coming
back to power of the
the pyrenees so because the experience
of
uh mccree has been a total disaster
total disaster you know and no and
people
people you know even the the if at some
point
they were a bit disappointed
with some problem of the
you know krishna government the moment
of the
really great success of left populist
movement
national popular woman they call
themselves it was a moment where the
price of
commodities were very high you know so
they get a lot of money for
the distribution and then of course
there was a crisis
and suddenly people would been
accustomed to you know
there was they could not the government
simply could not follow
the same thing so they've been some kind
of
disappointment oh you know we will
promise that
and of course i think that explain and i
follow the situation
in in in uh with korea for instance in
in ecuador also and they say okay maybe
let's and then obviously you know the
the the the
no no no you know we are going to um
bring back for an investment we are
going to really go
and let's okay let's try
but of course you know what they are
seeing is that this is absolutely
this attempt to reestablish your liberal
germany has been a
total disaster uh and so i think that
the sign for latin america are
really positive
for instance in uh in chile which is
also a little bit of different case but
we've got the growth of el frantejampio
is
movement so i think that we are about
hopefully
to see a return of the pink wave in
latin america
but nevertheless i mean there are things
that we've got to
to learn it is always very even even if
the situation are very different
not the question was okay you know we
are going to have a recipe to apply
but there is something to learn from
from the foreign what i will say
is that the fact that you can't put
everything on the question
of redistribution
making people you know happiest consumer
i mean you also need to create other
form of identity citizenship identity
you know so that even in moments in
which
the economic situation are not so good
people are not going to
uh simply vote in favor or in function
of their wallet you know
so i think that they they are a lesson
and of course well in in
when it comes to europe obviously we've
got to try to understand
you know what have been the problem for
instance
i think but if for me it has been very
very painful to have to come to this
conclusion
because i'm what you know people call a
left-wing europeanist
i must acknowledge that
at least so fast uh we
the experience of greece has shown that
you know it is not possible to put a
practice an anti-austerity
program anti-neoliberal program within
the context of the european union
you know so that that that's uh uh
that was a serious question and and and
i think it's
of course in in britain it's a bit
different
at least you will not ma even if there
is no leaving
of the brexit the fact that you have it
not in the euro
make a big difference you know because
in many places people say no
the euro has been such a straight jacket
that that is really the point in which
you know
so but yeah but there are some at least
a
question i need to ask and try to see
for instance
i would personally hope and and i do
believe
that a refoundation of the european
union is possible
and i know i mean people let me say no
it's impossible to reform the european
union the european union is
an intrinsically a nearly liberal
project the only way to leave okay but
what's the alternative
you know i i don't believe that uh
return to uh
the frank or the the the the marco
and it's what they call in france the
superheroness politics
so it it's a it's an important question
i think
and left populist parties need to
address that question you know what
should be what can but i
there are people who believe uh well let
let's
in in fact in britain the movement uh
remains reform and revolt in a sense it
goes into that direction amid
that okay but but yeah there are lessons
to learn
that's for sure i think that is a great
lesson to take from this interview
chantalmuth thank you very much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today
to the institute of art and ideas at iai
tv
you